welcome to the show long overdue
give it up for the one and only ricky
glor ladies and gentlemen give it up for
him everyone
thank you so much michael sarah yeah oh
he's starting with a roast
and i've gotta um i do not roast i am
like i would never put myself in a roast
i am not a roast comic people who can do
it
great like i can't that's just that's
the only one i have for
for tonight oh i see see shots fired and
then you're like but not
not me not little innocent on me
and then just a flag waved immediately
okay
okay i'll let that slide because you're
a special guest here but you know i i've
been
known to be cut out of a comedy central
taping of roast battles so don't get it
twisted
don't let the hair fool ya i've got
jokes that didn't make the cut for
comedy central so not to brag
it's all good so let us get into this q
and a with yogi bear here
and we will see yogi bear
did nobody see
i was trying to roast you but then
nobody laughed
if i'm yogi you are definitely boo boo
remember that in they do a dan aykroyd
in like
justin timberlake semi live action yogi
bear movie
did they like 2007 am i crazy
like he came and went like real quick
like on the heels of a little
excuse to do live action i don't know i
mean yes
you are crazy but i don't know if that's
part of it
what i'm doing i'm actually adjusting i
remember in our last q a here on zoom
that
i had to adjust like there's a green bar
that you know will show up in the middle
of zoom
yeah people were like you got to hide
that green bar
so this is me live on air
i'll fill in some space with some
useless movie knowledge of movies i've
never seen
uh yogi bear semi live action movie did
come out in 2010
uh very much in the bane of like the
scooby-doo movies with matthew lillard
starring uh dan aykroyd as yogi bear and
justin timberlake as boo boo
and tom kavanagh as ranger smith
interesting yep all right well with that
useful knowledge everyone left the chat
yeah everyone everyone's done now
let's um let's get in to you ricky and i
i i love i mean first off i just i'm a
fan and i'm always like keeping an eye
out for comics that are just
willing to just do things like it's very
easy in comedy to like
get lost in process or what if or but
that's harder i don't know how
but i really enjoy seeing comedians like
you
who are like just willing to just do
things you know and create
and really just try and it's working out
with all the success you've had
and it's only just the beginning with
this new album but i would really be
curious just to
yes yes and go um go support
his album as well that'll be linked in
the show notes i just bought it
everyone should buy it if you're a fan
of comedy go support i actually got one
of the limited edition uh signed ones
so oh okay
ones not to brag or anything but
get some liner notes get some extra
pictures of me with my baby
yeah daddy got a stimulus check from the
government he just blew it on ricky
galore's
signed album no but honestly if you're a
fan of comedy definitely go support what
ricky's doing here because it's an
inspiration
for all of us comics to really just you
don't have to wait on anyone get out
there and do it
so just to start off with can you give
us a little context yeah about like
um how long you've been doing comedy i
mean how this album came to be
kind of like your journey yeah i'll give
you a
a little bit of a cliff notes version
because i said before we started
i could ramble i could i could start
from the
the time that my mom and dad met at a
bar and started flirting with
one another before i was a gleam in
their eye but i won't um i started doing
stand-up in 2005
at uh newport on the levee funny bone
one of the funny bone franchises
which is owned by the improv and levity
live
that group and i it was one of those
shopping mall kind of comedy clubs oh
yeah like there's a forever 21 there's a
hot topic in there
and it was in northern kentucky right on
the river i was going to college
and i desperately wanted to be on the
college improv team
and i auditioned and i didn't make it
because my trajectory in my head was
get a theater degree then go to chicago
improv in college
go to chicago do improv olympics do
second city and then
i'll be on snl like i'll work for snl in
some way i'll change their ways
paperbacks
baskets i'll do something for snl uh-huh
so when that didn't happen i went a
little bit into panic mode because i was
like okay i have this creativity that i
want to get out
um but how can i do that i want to
entertain
so a friend of mine said well you know
they're offering stand-up classes
at funny bout and as much as i enjoyed
stand up
some of my favorites being seinfeld
robin williams
eddie murphy steve martin i um
i wasn't sure what the technique was to
do it
even though i was a writer and i had
done theater
i had never written something for myself
at that moment
so i went to the class and the comedian
teaching it was jeff
jenna who if you're not familiar with
him he's been in the business
forever in every fashion kind of like
you're talking about like television
movies
touring he has a dry bar special out as
well so check that out
yeah on the driver um so
when i took the class the first class
jeff started talking to us and he said
okay there's like 30 of you here if
if any of you came here thinking that i
will make you funnier
than what you are then you need
to not come to the next class which the
next class they they're charging
i love that and he said because the only
thing i can do
is that i can give you an outline of
writing prompts
and make you get on your feet and talk
in front of the class
for three minutes every class you're
guaranteed to talk in front of the class
based off a writing prompt you had the
week before
that's all i can do he said then i can
give you guidance for your voice
but he's like i'm gonna tell you now
finding the voice
is the hardest thing to do um
so he's like i can give you experience
and that means you don't have to
necessarily go to open mic bars
you still need to do that but you'll
also have this and at the end of the
class it culminates in a
showcase at the comedy club on a
wednesday night
and the room's packed because it's
filled with people that you've been
telling you're taking this class
exactly so it's everyone it's the best
possible audience
people who are attentive and just want
to see everyone succeed
so i took that class and
then i loved going and seeing stand-up
there
they used to offer a i think it's first
show friday first show
saturday you could be 18 and up and go
see a show
but then 21 and up for all shows
and kentucky has a weird law weird
liquor law that you can be 19 and a day
and be a server and work a place
that is just 21 and up so i put in an
application to work there
and got hired so i could see all the
shows because i wasn't 21 yet
smart and then you know i did uh i did
open mics
i did any wednesday show
that they had there at the club which
are usually sparsely attended
you sign up you know a couple weeks in
advance you get your five minutes
but at least you're at a club you know
there's a light and it's the stage and
uh because i worked there i got to hound
the gm
and i said you know i do stand up and
he's like oh god the last thing we need
is another work here who wants to do
this
and i say yeah but i think i'm getting
all right
on one of the wednesdays that you have
the open mics here can you watch my set
and see if i'm good enough to nc so he
did
and he's like yeah he's like you're good
enough to emcee like no skin off my
ass you know um and so
from that moment forward the first
weekend i did was in 2005 for finesse
mitchell
and then pretty much any time any
snl cast member or anyone who touched
the show came through
i would like put dibs on the on the dry
erase board
to see if i could emcee them and
i mean i could name drop everybody that
i got to mc for but it was
such a cool learning experience
in seeing how comics
use their energy on stage especially as
headliner sets
they don't waste you know like someone
like jim brewer
which was i had already been emceeing
for a couple years
uh quick story this was it was the
thursday night and
neither jim or the feature act were
there and the sound guy came down
mike and he was like jim and the feature
act aren't here
uh you got to go on stage which at that
time i could only do like 12 minutes
and he's like ah i'm gonna if you're
done with your set
and they're not here i'm gonna blinky
light you to keep going do crowd work
and i'm like okay um and he's like but
if i hard light you if i just leave it
on they're here
introduce just say and ladies and
gentlemen your feature
com comic tonight because they didn't
know who was coming
so then the music starts like ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the funny moment
it's a thursday and so that's playing
and i'm already in my head like
okay how much more than 12 minutes do i
have do i have jokes that i've thrown
away that i could put in the middle
because they're not as strong so i want
to sandwich them
and as i'm doing this as i'm like
sitting there like rain man trying to do
some like quantum physics of jokes
uh jim brewer comes running up to me and
he's like
hey man i'm jim uh we only have a
feature act this weekend
so you do 30 minutes and then just bring
me up okay i have a great show
and then leaves and i'm like
i don't have 30 minutes
right and i've never just brought up you
know
usually you do the announcements
you know the specials of food you say
eddie griffin's gonna be here next
weekend so get your tickets now
do you guys like bruce bruce because
he's coming at the end of the month
you know um how long did your career was
this by the way
i think i was this is two years in two
years in
doing 30 minutes unexpectedly in front
of jim brewer
a sold-out weekend like the weekend's
already sold out before i
start oh my god so there's that also
with that is
you know do you know the um jerry
seinfeld documentary comedian
of course yeah yeah no orny adams
right that movie paints a very specific
picture of orny um
the movie comedian with the commentary
with colin quinn and seinfeld and the
movie itself
are kind of my comedy bible every every
about
six months i watch it either the
commentary or just the movie
i still do just to brush up on some bits
of wisdom that orny puts out there
in seinfeld and other comics put out
there um
orny was coming through the funny bone
and this is like 2009 so i've been doing
comedy for four years
i'm featuring now some when the
headliners aren't bringing in their
their features but orny's coming through
and i'm not working that weekend
i'm not performing and i'm not serving
so i went and saw the show on a thursday
night
and i was talking to him afterwards and
he said oh what do you do and i said i'm
a server here but i also do stand up
and i was already predispositioned
from hearing some other stories about
orny and seeing the documentary
to think that he might be a little bit
of a diva
or a little bit difficult and i'm
talking to him and he's talking to me
like a peer even though he has no idea
who i am right and i'm
not giving him any credentials and he
says oh great your comic too he's like
you want to come and do uh guest sets
this weekend
and i was like yeah he's like yeah he's
like just come every show and he's like
and you can do a 10 buck guest set and
i'll make sure
that whatever you want to eat or drink
that the green room takes care of wow
and then so i invited my parents to come
see the sunday night show
because the sweetest thing about a guest
set is you go on
after the mc so you kind of have that
cushion
like you would a feature act there's no
expectations because they introduce you
as being a very special guest is on the
show tonight
so the audience is like oh i don't know
who it is but maybe he's someone special
um and orny did one of the best
50 minutes of comedy that i've ever seen
of like
energy material was so
good and his generosity just blew me
away because
friday night i could have gone up for a
show and been like
orneo sucks and dropped the mic and
walked away
and but you know he heard i was a comic
felt good about giving someone a slot on
the show you know maybe he was working
new material
so he didn't have his full headliner i
don't know what the
reason was it was just super nice but
how did the
how did the 30 minute set go with jim
brewer
it was good i uh it talked to me and
learned
taught me how to talk slur nice i got
through it i definitely
you know i kind of talked to uh brewer
that weekend about like oh i've never
done that much he's like oh you're doing
good and he's like
i think you should do more on this i
think you should do more on that wow
comedians
most of the time if they're what i
learned was and this might not always be
true
if you heard of them most of the time
they're pretty decent people
if they're up and coming and you haven't
heard of them they're good people if
you've
kind of heard of them like they're on
that sitcom once in like 96
it's a lot of times they were dicks but
that's not
like name dropping anybody but like so
that taught me a lot
and after i was house and seeing and
featuring for a while
i then graduated college and went to
chicago where
i kind of did stand up for a little bit
but i put it on the back burner i was
doing a lot of improv doing second city
improv olympics my first week there i
was serving at second city
and i got to see lauren michael seth
meyer seth meyers
michael uh michael shoemaker and uh
higgins
come and watch uh people performing in
shows to cast them for snl
three days in a row my first week up
there so that was
stupid surreal but then i
performed i wrote musicals i did a lot
of storefront theater
and i did a lot of improv which i kind
of stopped doing
when i realized that people didn't put
the time and thought to it
as much or the commitment so i got more
into theater again
and then when i moved back to kentucky
in 2017
i was like okay i want to do stand-up
again and i want to start working on a
headliner set
and start pushing myself to get 45
minutes
and so from 2017 to this past february
was just laser focusing on that hmm
and this this can really um tie into
our first question as well and thinking
of
i got um i asked you like kind of how
you got started and everything
and this actually helps in terms of word
economy
of answering questions
[Laughter]
and it's funny because one of the tips
for young stand-ups
is to write it out and then go through
with a pen or delete
words that you can delete and this
the joke still makes sense even though i
don't do that with my answers but yeah i
just thought that would be a perfect
segue into the first question but you
did preface this with that you like
and it was all relevant information i
just thought it was a good opportunity
to um though you came out swinging with
michael sarah i'm on my toes now
i cannot be the first and only person
who's ever said that oh no i've taken
photos as michael sarah
before like i just played along
yeah um but uh i do have more questions
as well but we'll get to people's
questions as they come in but this one
comes from mike
jackson and he asks uh
i write daily but i think my setups are
still too long
any advice for a shorter yet clear
setup yeah avoid asking questions i'm
not sure if mike does this
um i think the quickest way
to kill a joke is to ask a question or
to ask the audience
because they're all uh they are
you're never gonna an answer from the
audience
is never gonna dictate where you're
going
unless you're riffing so don't ask a
question
like who here has done this it doesn't
matter
the thing you're going to be talking
about you're probably talking about
because it's so relatable
that everyone has done it or if they
haven't
you're going to present it in a way
that's going to sound like the
juxtaposition of something that is
supernatural and like everyone does this
right
no one does this you know so
i think eliminating anything that you
question the thing i said before and
this is the seinfeld thing
is write it depending on if you if you
physically write or if you type
um i usually type
and then i hand write to memorize
um and then i go back for a third step
is to then type it again with what i
remember um and then check back and see
how close it was
because i really like for cadence and
for flow
um i like to know what it is i think uh
there's a lot of different kinds of
stand-ups some stand-ups
do are incredibly naturalistic i feel
like i'm more of a vaudeville stand-up
i'm a song and dance man like i like to
do everything
yeah uh i grew up on open crosby like
i grew up on marx brothers and stuff and
loved watching the monkeys growing up
and so i like kind of giving a whole
show
um to answer more of the writing
go through and literally
eliminate any word that you can
and keep on reading it until you've
eliminated all the words you can
without it sounding like broken speech
um i would say setups and segways are
not as important
as people make it seem to be
that if you feel that it's a weird segue
as long as the timber of your voice and
the tone of your voice
has made it clear that you're moving on
then do that and don't worry also in the
performing aspect of the material that
you feel like is a little too long
is if something doesn't get a laugh or
response that you think it needs
you're hopefully recording the audio of
yourself
because i don't think videos is
important you don't need a type 5 video
to send to nbc
when you're first starting off i like
the branded mug
i just saw it because we out there
you saw this somewhere yeah on my
website joelbyerscomedy.com
buy that that's a hot that's a hot mug
i think audio because audio is so
important i think when you're starting
off and you're doing a lot of five to
ten minute sets
not you're not listening for laughs a
lot i think what you should be listening
for is
do you understand what you're saying by
hearing the audio
because sometimes if an audience doesn't
laugh
oh god it could be a hundred different
permutations and reasons it could be
it's not funny that's the worst case
you should still try it and try it in
different parts of your set could be
you're saying it too fast and the people
aren't understanding the words
you're not articulating it enough or
enunciating
um and so record the audio
and then when you're listening back to
if you're like okay i can hear what i'm
saying and it's still not getting the
laughs
what can i do now to go back and get to
the joke quicker
the second city rule of writing sketch
comedy
is that you start at the most
interesting point so if it's a husband
and wife scene
where the wife is gonna get pregnant or
is going to give birth to the baby in
the scene
start with her giving birth like don't
start
with them leading up being like oh i
think i'm going to have the baby today
it's like no
get to the most interest what is the
crux of your scene
so i think if you start there in
a joke with the littlest lead up you
don't have to make sure that the
audience is on the
same page you don't have to make sure
that the audience is seen every season
of game of thrones
just like whatever you're talking about
just get to it like they'll be on board
yeah and another one that i find helpful
is also understanding what you're even
trying to say with the joke so like what
is the premise of the joke
what what are you even trying to say can
really help to start to
edit out those unnecessary words like
ricky was talking about
but that's something that comes up in
the right tin club
that it's like a daily writing challenge
we do in this facebook group where we
get a random word and then write for 10
minutes
and see who can you know write funny
jokes when we give feedback but the big
thing is a lot of the times if the joke
is too wordy it's because
the comic doesn't even know exactly what
the premise of the joke is
so it's good to reverse back to what am
i even trying to say
and that'll help majorly reverse
engineer where's your punch and how long
did it take
for you to get there how strong is the
punch and how
dramatic and performative
is your lead and to get to that punch is
it entertaining is it filled with jokes
as well um another great way now that we
have twitter
is even it doesn't matter about like oh
why should i write like no one's
following me no one's retweet no one's
liking
doesn't matter send it out into the
ether it's there granted
be sure that you're not just diarrheaing
and if you do
touch any bit of success five years from
now that you don't have this random
racist tweet
or homophobic tweet but use that because
that is
a that is they're putting permutations
on you of how many words you can say
so if you're trying to write to
entertain in that avenue
then you're really writing probably
distilling the joke to the longest that
it needs to be
in a performance and then
what's great about it is if you follow a
lot of comedians or you have comic
friends
they might inspire you with the tags
they put on it
because comics love nothing more
than replying with the joke that they're
like
i think this one's funnier which may
then go to you be like oh that doesn't
fit my voice or
where i'm going but that does make me
think that it could be this
or if it's a really good tag that you
like that you're like man that really
does help this joke
message them or if you know them talk to
them say would you mind
if i use this joke in ninety percent of
the time they'll be fine with it
the ten percent of the time is if you
don't ask them and then they hear it or
see about it
later of you perpetuating that it's
something you came up with
that's just bad you know that's bad
business yeah i would be interested to
even
jump into the business side a little bit
and touching on you saying if you blow
up
and then in five years like they see
this racist tweet like something i'd
i'm uh i admire about you is like your
your branding like your dry bar special
is dad bod your
album is spitting image and there's an
image of you with a microphone
holding your baby there's like you have
a great website that's very well
polished like you seem
to not only focus on the craft but also
in show business the show but also
the business side of this game so do you
do you have any insight or it's just
i've noticed that for myself as well
like i try to be mindful of it because i
feel like so many comics overlook that
so i just really notice it when a comic
like my comedy special is called the
trophy husband like i'm really working
on
branding and it so like it seems like
that's something you're focused on as
well
uh where did that come from and like
what kind of tips do you have for how
you were able to develop such a cohesive
brand identity i think a little bit of
it
since i mentioned before about being
such a fan and a student of the monkeys
they are a prefabricated group that was
that were
extremely for talented people who were
then
packaged by two people
two producers and creators that were
trying to buck the system at the time
um bob rafelson and bert schneider i'm
gonna mention things that aren't gonna
matter to anybody but if you were to
look into it
they weren't cigar chomping guys they
were hippie guys
burt schneider was the son of abe
schneider who ran
columbia studios back in the 60s
so he was kind of a hippie guy you know
bob rafelson and burt schneider spun the
money they made for the monkeys
and made five easy pieces an easy rider
they started turning hollywood on its
head
of being these indie produced movies
that were actually speaking to the
counter culture but what they did with
the monkeys is
they recognized what was unique about
each one
they didn't say let's do the beatles on
tv and this guy's ringo this guy's paul
this guy's john
they went no mike nesmeth he's got a
southern drawl
he's kind of a jimmy stewart quality
let's not make him be something he's not
let's use this guy
davey jones oh he's cute he's small he's
unassuming
he is going to be our teen heartthrob
mickey dolan's a little goofy looking
kind of funny
good like they knew what they had
and they didn't fight against it this
goes in i think the business of being
your own
promoter as a comedian
is one of the hardest things that comics
strive for which is the comics voice
and i don't know i don't have my voice
down pat
i've read i mean i know you're not
supposed to i've read the comments on
the dry bar clips that they put on
youtube
where you know 60 000 people have
watched it and commented or whatever
and like you're not supposed to read the
comments but like a couple people are
like
this guy's delivery sounds like he's
asking a question every time he's
talking even though i said don't ask
questions
um so like i read that though and i want
to take into account i'm like
does my voice have that roller coaster
kind of like
like maybe it does and maybe that's
something i need to work on
but the thing i have found in my voice
is
not trying to be something that i'm not
especially in stand-up
i'm growing in the sense of there are
some
topics that on my next hour i am going
to talk about or i'm going to try
and maybe it's not going to work and i
don't consider it pandering
but there's a segment on guns that i
want to
try to work out but i also know as a
comic
i'm not going to put it at the beginning
of my set and i'm not going to put it at
the end of my set
i'm going to put it right in the middle
so hopefully you already liked me for my
first 15 minutes
so then this next five minutes where i
talk about guns
isn't incredibly polarizing but could
clinch a couple buttholes
in the audience depending where i'm
playing and then when i'm done with it
hopefully you know you aren't so
offended by what i said because i don't
think it is
offensive that you're still with me
maybe you even thought it was funny and
you didn't
think it was as political as it was but
then i'm gonna finish out and you're not
even gonna remember that bit if you
didn't like it
but for the business side of things
talking about
starting off at the funny bone doing
open mics and emceeing
i've gone through my old uh black and
white notebooks those
uh composite notebooks and
i didn't talk about anything personal
probably
until i actually started back up again
in 2017
i had the burt reynolds story that you
can hear on the album
that they cut from drybar which is
interesting which i think it's because
it's about stealing
and the mormons didn't want to talk
about stealing right
which is super interesting um
but like i had that story that happened
to me
i went to campbell county high school in
kentucky where our mascot was a camel
and our colors were purple and gold that
it all happened to me
when i was first starting off in
stand-up
i recognized that that was funny and
that was funny to me
but nowhere in my mind could i access
and think
that that was worthy material to present
to an audience
so i look back at my old notebooks and
i'm
weirdly dirty not vulgar but like
cursing a lot and stuff and i don't
typically curse a bunch when i talk
um there's no reason for it
i'm not incredibly religious um i'm
agnostic
i believe there's something i don't know
what it is so
i it astonishes me anybody that's like
this is my religion and anything else is
wrong
but as long as your religion doesn't
hurt somebody else it tells you to go
cause someone else pain doesn't bug me
when did you
start packaging it into like an actual
business
i mean dad bought and spitting it like
you're clearly being
i i like like you're saying well when i
started getting more personal on stage i
started to figure out what was unique to
me
that's when you seem to really start
getting traction so is that from the
branding side of like
what is unique about me and then how can
i
almost just create not a character but
almost like an identity like an
exaggerated version of
myself yeah um it also came with
embracing with what
i like doing on stage and not feeling
shameful from other comedians
[Music]
right like no how many times has
the comedian gone up with a with a
guitar and an open mic or whatever
and every comic in the audience who's
who has already gone up or is about to
go up is like
here's this hacky comedian with a guitar
guilty
i've done it too i 100 percent have done
it
and yes a lot of times they will prove
you right you know but there are
there are your stephen lynches who
you don't hear about much anymore there
are your adam sandlers
who you know who can destroy
and be incredibly you know prolific
with their comedy with an instrument
there can be your dmitry martins or your
zac gilifinakis
who incorporate their instrument in such
a way
that you think of that instrument being
in their appendage
like when like there's a comic that
who got compared to dimitri martin and
it burned him up starting off
is mike berbiglia uh he hated
everyone in new york when he went to new
york when he moved from washington was
like
ah you're really good you know you
should check out mike barbigal and he's
like i know
i've heard that before um
but so do you remember have you watched
berbegley as early stuff
not me he closes his show he closes his
show by playing a guitar
and like that seemed a little demetry
martin-esque of
the kind of like the late 90s early
2000s
scene where i would guess dimitri martin
is musically inclined
as berbiglia probably plays guitar but
isn't that super you know
experienced on it but i think those guys
were also trying to find something that
they could do
so their name wouldn't be likened to
like mitch hedberg
all the time who is another comic very
much like them
did a lot of one-liners now berbiglia
flash forward not to diminish me dimitri
martin
he still performs but like brabiglia
shifted
into being a one-man show where he's
telling these long
stories so i feel like he evolved
into a commute the comedian the
entertainer that he wanted to be
you know with the films that he's making
too that are incredibly personal
that i really respect but then there are
stand-ups who are naysayers and are like
oh
well what hannah gatsby does and what
micro biglia does
that's not stand up that's one man show
and it's like
is their goal to entertain and make you
laugh
like is that the first bullet point i
think so
so why isn't that a variation of
stand-up
where like if you went to him if you
went to a video store
which you can't anymore and you saw the
horse
or if like you looked on netflix horror
movies
there are sub genres of thriller
suspense
mystery a lot of times are considered
horror
why aren't those those sub genres are
just as valid
is a movie just labeling itself as
horror
so why can't that be the same thing for
performance and like stand up
whether it's a musical stand-up whether
it's someone who does impressions
am i gonna do impressions in my next
hour
maybe like i have a jack black
compression that
i started working on after this hour
happened that i was like oh maybe i'll
do
i have a patrick stewart dramatically
reading uh ice ice baby
that didn't make it into this thing and
like but then i think i'm like but i
also
you know i do sean connery which people
can be like oh everyone does shane
connor
like i don't do christopher walken
because it didn't
i don't i like christopher walken but it
doesn't connect to me the way that like
sean connery dramatically reading safety
dance
does of like my love for james bond and
like the untouchables
so the branding for me didn't come from
well i need to brand to really you know
isolate it down to the singularity
of this package that i need to sell it
just
it went with being a writer and i'm like
well what's the narrative well the
narrative
is this and
you know like for dry bar i gave them
the picture of me
they did a photo session and that's
whatever picture they have in me holding
a microphone
looking way thinner than i actually am
i'm like that's it i think they made me
skinnier
um but like i gave them a picture of me
with uh anna my daughter in the front
pouch
the one that i ended up using for my
album and they asked me what do i want
to call the album and i said i think dad
bod
because that's a joke that happens very
early on i think that's
yes it is trying to think of like oh
what's a a hashtag or like
something that is talked about a lot
in an easy sell because i also
they took pictures of me playing the
ukulele which they didn't use this
the song i played in the special so
luckily
i told them i was like i don't think you
want to get many pictures of me playing
the ukulele i would play one song
at that time for the special because
it's only 20
they only record 25 minutes but they
ended up not using it anyway so it's
good
but like i
i wanted it to be something that
wasn't um misleading to anyone who might
click it to
like i didn't want a title to be
something
that might make someone think that like
i'm an edgy comic
because then they're going to click play
looking for like
you know someone who's talking about
politics there's like finger on the
pulse and is really cool
that's not how i would perpetuate myself
so
i was like dead bod it's a joke that
happens like in the first 10 minutes
um i talk about a lot at the top
they're going to click it they're going
to hear that dad bought joke they're
going to talk
me talking about my daughter they're not
it's not going to be a bait and switch
yeah and it sounds like um and thank you
everyone posting with your
your questions here i will get to them
after this one because this is something
i've been curious about and uh glenn
tickle actually
just posted a link he posted a link
to um ricky's album that you can go pick
up
but um glenn is a fantastic comic please
watch his if you have amazon prime good
grief
got it the special special that he did
about his brother's passing
you want to talk about a a specific
show that could be about something that
you click
and be very sad when you when you read
the description
but i think it makes it's a it's very
cathartic i knew it was cathartic for
glenn
but cathartic for you and any loss
you've had big or small
watching it define the cathartic nature
of
humor even if it's not your own of
relying on humor
to help you express your emotions
through whatever tragedy
like i said big or small that you've had
in your life so yeah
he has a dry bar coming out too i think
it should be within the next couple
months yeah a lot of people
getting these dry bars what it sounds
like who are they
getting these no no i'm not like jealous
i'm just thinking like
um um like what it
what's the deal with this dry bar like
it seems like
what's the nail of these but then it
seems like they have full ownership do
you just get paid a flat fee
do you get part of the back end what's
the what's the payment structure on this
dry bar deal they're throwing away
not throwing away but like throwing out
there that a lot of people
see value in
yeah how their business acumen of how
exactly they make money
i couldn't probably i couldn't give you
a good dissertation on that
for the comedian you get all expenses
paid
you do two shows in one night uh
they are now doing them they used to do
40 minutes they're now doing 20 to 25
minutes
the hardest thing is i know
that it's a clean show and they're
stringent on the subject of material
like i said jeff jenna was my stand-up
coach
i've opened for him and worked with him
he's been a little bit of a mentor
because he already did one i sent him my
show and he very graciously
uh watched it and read my set
and gave me notes and pointers of where
like he thought things should go
or because i was already working on a
headliner set
when i got booked for it last
july and then i recorded in september
um so i knew it would be 25 minutes of
my 45 minute headliner show
so i was like oh okay i want to do
like my best first 10
and my best like cobbled last 15 to make
that 25
and not do the middle or and not do
things that i knew they wouldn't be cool
with if they
fly you out there and then they charge
on the app so do you get a cut of some
like every time do not charge on the app
oh the app is free okay
the app is free so you can watch how
many ever specials that they have
for free they charge if you want to
download it and own it
via like if you were to rent it um it's
not written
though it's like you can watch it
whatever for that
so you don't have to watch it on your
phone you can watch it on your tv or
whatever kind of like
amazon prime um so they fly you down all
expenses paid they put you up the night
before
and the night of um and they pay for the
rental car if you have to rent a car
um they pay you for both shows
a decent wage a headliner wage um and
there are three people most of the time
on the show my night it was steve guyer
who's an older comedian who is
a gem of a person he's super nice and
cam bertram following me jacksonville
who's this
yeah who's like 25 extremely white and
has the voice of chris rock
like the sound of him and
seeing him couldn't be like
diametrically opposed
like in any other comedian but he's a
delight so
imagine seeing me cam and steve an older
comedian
in one night that's such a different
like
set of comedians that you would see at
any comedy club because they'd never
make it
that like different of voices
um so then yeah they pay you for two
nights makeup
there's like 10 cameras it's
always a sold out show it's packed the
audience is amazing they have an
mc who recorded the night before
so uh if they have
a friday show i think they'd bring in
someone from the next day i think they
might have been steve who
emceed that night or a local comic and
then so they slay
they give the credits before they bring
you out on stage
they put you in makeup and hair you get
food throughout the day
i mean it's the you it's
the most taken care of that you'll be oh
that's great
like until you do a comedy central
special i'm sure
it's good to know yeah i've never heard
the behind the scenes so that's good
but they also don't tell you what you
can or cannot do
so like i'm friends with jeff jenna and
erica rhodes
who had both recorded a special so they
like said luckily looked at myself and
they gave me some pointers
i have a kentucky creationist bit
that doesn't really make fun of the
creationist museum
it just talks about it and brings it up
but
they both were like yeah i wouldn't do
that because it just mentions religion
like and that just might be something
that doesn't you know tickle their fancy
so i didn't do that so i knew not to do
that but i reached out to the producers
of dry bar the bookers and i was like
hey do you want me to send you a video
or the text of what i plan on doing
and they're like no we trust you and so
there's a little bit of paranoia of like
okay i hope i don't do something like i
would have never thought that the burt
reynolds story
would have been something that they
wouldn't have been cool about
never know so let's start running
through these people's questions here
uh we got people popping in saying this
is great
it's um yeah mike's saying thanks for
answering my question real helpful
michelle um fyi really enjoying this
interview thanks joel and ricky
um jason irvin saying ricky is very
talented who has a lot of passion for
his craft
jason irvin was the makeup man before
the pandemic happened
we filmed the opening to a horror movie
that i wrote and he does hair and makeup
and special effects and unfortunately
that has not been able
to get edited it's a it's a horror movie
that i was going to use that opening to
try to make the whole thing
get the budget but he's awesome yeah a
lot a lot of people are
enjoying this so let's get to their
questions here
like like there's ever going to be
people like this is awful
why is this still going this isn't on
youtube yet but i i've
this show will be on youtube and i've
seen enough of our comments to know
like every every other comment is like
this white boy's laugh is so
fake that's like half of the comments
about my
my laugh as everyone thinks it's fake
it's not
michael sarah needs to be canceled
it's only fake when it's for ricky
they're real all the other times
so um let's try to run through these bob
jorgensen
he actually just joined uh the group
last week and he's been in the right ten
club
every day so this is um this is a comic
really committed and he actually started
later in life so he's asking
do either of you have any advice for a
comic starting later in life
late 40s married with kids
yes do not um try to
do edgy material
i mean but that's just me as a
preference i've seen a lot of
later in life comedians or older people
starting off
women or men um surprisingly more women
than men
and they try to be shocking on stage to
elicit a reaction kind of what i would
call the um
the betty white syndrome or the woman
who played
the old woman in the wedding singer
where they're like oh i didn't i bet you
didn't expect for a dad to talk
like this um that may
serve you in the shows that you're doing
but i don't think that's gonna serve you
for a longevity if this is something you
actually want to do
so i would just talk about what
what makes you laugh like what kind of
comedian do you want to be
is it a one-liner is it a story like and
just really work
on that and do as many shows as you can
do yeah and i think it and it's hard
it's hard with definitely like row club
yeah
like the bro club of like comics young
comics who want to go out and party
after every show
like you don't have to do that either do
the show be nice
um push yourself to do shows out of
state and this goes for any
age of comedian like uh just don't do
the same
show at the comedy like
don't make a um don't make a mecca
don't think that the comedy club that
you really want to get stage time at
is the end-all be-all because one bad
thing
is that the people who usually run that
will never see you beyond
the set you did the first time there no
matter how good you get they'll always
see you kind of as that comic or
that persona or the nerves or the
jitters or whatever
subjects you talked about um push
yourself book
get two other comics that you think are
way better than you and you think it can
do more time
and do the leg work to book a brewery or
a winery once they're open
outside you know even 30 miles
or 100 miles outside of where you live
drive make the arrangements to get paid
always get paid
don't do a free show get paid something
because if you're booking two comedians
that you think are better than you
and the package you're selling and
you're saying we're gonna do at least an
hour to an hour and a half of stand up
if you're not used to doing mc work
force yourself to emcee those first few
shows
and then start rotating yourself into
the feature spot if you can
if you get like a 15 to 20 minutes and
book live entertainment for these places
that are the new modern day coffee house
who
the breweries and the wineries the best
thing about them is they have alcohol
they usually have some sort of appetizer
or food
which makes them destinations where
people just don't pass through
they'll stay and they'll have they'll
hang out a little bit and some
for some places they're always in the
corn fields of these cities
but that could be a couple's night out
their date night
so put together a good show and treat it
like it is a show at a comedy club
even though you don't need stage lights
you don't need the best sound system
get a couple speakers and a microphone
and bring your own equipment so when the
place is like oh we'd love to book you
for 300
where each comedian gets 100 or
something or you get 150 to cover your
gas if you're driving
um and they're like well we don't have
equipment be like oh it's okay we got a
microphone
and speakers and you bring the show to
them and they're like great
because they're gonna get a little bit
extra money and it's up to them
get a flat fee don't do a door fee
your show is better than that granted
the audience has always paid more by
just showing up
if they want to do a free show with you
getting a flat fee
that's on them but be confident in the
other comedians that you're bringing
and yourself that even as mc your
10-minute set
and your hosting is going to be worth
them paying the 300 to get you there
and to promote that their venue has live
entertainment
nice good advice next one is from glenn
tickle
he asks uh why did you want to go
through a label
instead of self-releasing your album
hmm um because
i was googling how
uh what labels were good for
young comedians and i came across an
article where glenn tickle was
spotlighted
for self-releasing and creating a record
label
just for himself and let's say that the
album
did so yeah and so that his album did
so well that when billboard 100 called
him
to get to verify the information on the
record label
that the album was being released on he
had to give it a name
to which he said circus trapeze records
which is a joke in his act on his on
that album
so then began him starting a label
mostly for comedians who know who
already
he already knew who he already had a lot
of the paperwork for
and they were like well i'd like put an
album to sell at shows and he was like
okay yeah okay join mine
uh i'll do it because you know me and
you know we're we're friends and we
won't screw each other
and blah blah blah if there's something
that you don't like we'll make it right
so i reached out to him and i was like
look i legit want to release an album
and i want a label that would be
enthusiastic
behind releasing mine and i contacted
him before dry bar
i'd been on bob and tom i had written
for ifc
but except for name dropping some people
i opened for i really didn't have any
credits
and kind of like in theater a resume
is only as good as much that you can
substantiate like how good you are to
match the resume
it's just a piece of paper with credits
um
if you don't have the goods then who
cares that you were you know angel and
rent
in your community theater production of
rent it could have been a really bad
production and you were the brightest
turd
but so i reached out to glenn and i said
oh
i really like your album and i listened
to it before reaching out to him
would you be interested in producing
mine i got this
form letter it was very much you know
like when you read an email you're like
oh this is copy and paste
and like my name has been like inserted
like dear ricky
you know um saying
if you read the art thank you so much
for reaching out if you read the article
i detailed how
it's way more beneficial for you to
release it yourself and blah blah and do
all this and do all this
thank you for reaching out glenn tickle
and i said
cool yeah i get that i don't want to do
that
because i do it enough i am my own agent
and book or whatever
i also not to pat myself on the back
like
i want the prestige of a label
being interested in what i'm doing to
get behind
so it's not oh ricky glor you know
he's his own biggest promoter he's
putting out an album like
yeah of course he's putting out like
anybody can put out if you want to spend
money you can put out an album
um and he responded and he was like
okay but like let's talk about a little
bit more
but i really think you should just put
out yourself it's the most beneficiary
you know you're on the road you can make
more money off of it that way
i replied yeah i was like i still want
it to be that way and i said okay
how about this i've got a show in upper
pennsylvania
he's in new jersey i was like at a
winery
i was like how about if you're
interested you come down and feature for
me because i already knew it was
phenomenal and he's a great headliner
himself
come feature for me bring an mc whatever
you want the pay is this
um if you like my show
produce the album under the label if you
don't
or even if you do and you still don't
want to fine so we came
we had a great time the show was awesome
the mic cut out during the mc so we were
michaelis for the rest of the night in
front of like this 150 people
um and we had a great time and
afterwards he's like yeah he's like
let's do it
so you know he said you know he thinks
i'm funny and he likes
you know what i do but i would imagine
that part of him saw
the uh brand appeal that had to be
because
from the business side of him partially
you have to look at it that way and go
okay if i'm gonna put this work and this
money behind this is this gonna be
lucrative to me
which one of the next moves is he sends
it off to sirius
xm with it being a completely clean
album
some i don't know if it was glenn
someone said to me and i'm gonna
misquote numbers it's just for effect
the numbers i'm gonna say that they get
3 000 submissions a week
of explicit comic albums
so they can only play so many of those
because a lot of people that listen to
the comedy and siriusxm
sometimes put the parameters for
language
i think he he or someone else said they
only get
500 or like 200 submissions a week
of 100 clean comedians
so your percentages of getting picked up
and getting money from that because of
the ad pay
is so much higher so
i would think glenn being a businessman
and thinking that it was
funny in his own opinion
because comics have opinions of what
they think is funny is not
which also varies from what their taste
is like
my taste if you would classify me as and
i'm not saying as talented or funny
is like a jim gaffigan or a brian regan
that's not necessarily the comics i'm
drawn to
like i like watching a
like i said hannah gatsby or a john
mullaney
who you know they're not clean comics
um but so i would imagine he looked at
that and went okay
even if album sales aren't great or
itunes
sales if i pitch this to siriusxm
i might get a couple tracks from this
that get some air time
and that's where the money comes in
that's the business answer of it
which isn't like sexy or glamorous no
that's what people need to know though
yeah that's why that's why it was asked
yeah
um the next one we kind of got two
people asking similar things
um we have jake ruble and mark mitchell
here
both asking about the creating a
45-minute set and uh mark asked how much
did you go through to get the 45 minutes
but jake is asking
and how did you know your 45 minutes was
done
he has issues always wanting to keep
tweaking his material
so maybe how much materials you have to
create and then when did you know okay
what i've created is
enough and ready
um i'm also happy to answer all the
questions that they post as long as
you're
yeah oh yeah yeah this one
oh no i get it yeah i just didn't want
you to think like like oh like
we're gonna have to cut some of these
questions oh we got it no those are both
those are both really good questions and
uh
as neurotic as all even comedians that
have
their their [ __ ] together um
we're all neurotic like so recording
this
album on february 15th the day after
valentine's day show
i came from indiana doing a sold out
show on valentine's day
a show at a winery that dinner was
included
a glass of champagne was included it's
all couples
all wanting to have a good night out i
was like
this could either be the worst show to
do before a night of two recordings for
an album
also driving having to drive eight hours
the next day to pittsburgh
or it could be great it could be the
easiest layup of people just wanting to
have a good time and it'll give me an
energy boost
ended up being a fine show
but it did get me in my head of like
running time in bits and being like oh
well that didn't work as well as it
usually does
should i get rid of it should i
substitute this bit that i haven't done
as much
oh blah blah blah and this isn't this is
gonna happen regardless like that's not
saying like don't do a show a night
before
because if do as many shows as you can
but then
in pittsburgh at the club i think it
held um
a hundred people and i already knew that
the first show was sold out for the
album recording
and we're recording both shows and glenn
was featuring
which is great because he's he's a
fantastic fantastic comedian
um and our styles are different enough
that it doesn't feel like you're seeing
the
you know we're both dads he's a dad of a
seven-year-old and a
a two-year-old i think or a
three-year-old um
and the emcee was uh the
uh the couple who runs the comedy club
there
and it's got a great vibe it had a jazz
kind of feel
and the first show was sold out and
it went great and it was the show that
is the album
because the second show was about half
full i don't know why people bought
tickets they knew it was an album
recording
couldn't have acted like they didn't
want to be there like any
like it was nuts like i i'm not a
comedian
i hate comedians who get upset with an
audience on stage
who berate them for not laughing it's
like
there's no reason for that like my least
favorite comedian is the comic who goes
on stage who wants to show you how funny
they are
because for me in a little bit of what i
project on other comics is
your number one goal should be there to
entertain
the person who came um
and you should do it the best that you
can with what you've prepared
not to be that like that dorche couldn't
open and you could go to you could chase
rabbits and
do improvs that are great and lead your
way to like
another new five minutes but the 45
minutes that i did
i had honed i had done the two dry bar
shows
i had already known i already saw um a
clip
of a rough edit of what they were gonna
release as the special
so a little bit in my mind went okay so
that's what they think the the strongest
22 minutes are
of the 25 26 that i did there
um narratively being a playwright and a
screenwriter as well
i was like i think this 45 minutes
encapsulates
the best story of who i am and the
narrative that i'm trying to
to sell or put out there as a show of
like a beginning middle and end
um and at some point
you just have to start
going well that's the show i can still
write i can still try stuff
but you kind of have to know what the
show is
and do it regardless of like the times
you want to second-guess yourself and be
like well that didn't work i should
write a whole new bit
that fits in here granted like i was
still writing
some a couple one-liners
throughout the time leading up to the
show that i felt
fit the narrative and worked well enough
every time i did the show
up to the day of the show but like a bit
that i
used to do uh so for two years the brew
crew comedy tour is one of the pages
following us
that's a show i did at brewery's and
wineries
where i would book the show and book two
other comics and we would rotate
every show who was the emcee the feature
and the headliner
so we would each stretch our legs in
each one of those positions
so that was 2017-2018
from 2018 to 2019
i told every comedian that i had done
those shows with and i said hey
i'm going to start being selfish i'm
gonna book
the shows and make myself the headliner
for all the shows
because my goal is an album and a
special
so i started doing that so i stretched
the legs of the 45-minute set
every time we performed um something i
used to do in my set and i
may even go back to for my new hour
is in the middle of my show i would do a
thing called napkin thoughts
and that's i would set it up by saying
um we all have tiny computers that's my
baby by the way that's why the album is
called spitting up match
i would say we all have tiny computers
in our pockets
i still like to write my thoughts down
on napkins so here are some of my
napkin thoughts and i would legit pull
out napkins where i had written
one-liners or non-sequiturs on and that
would be
about a a six-minute chunk in my act
where i would test out new ideas
where because of the way i presented the
idea of the bit of the mean napkin
thoughts
just thoughts is i could do anything
because they didn't have to connect to
one another and then if i came up with
multiples that fit the same narrative or
the same joke
then i would turn that into a bit and i
would move it out of napkin thoughts
and i would put it into my act it's
great lowers the
so the bar and lowers
the pressure on the joke you're like
that's just a napkin thought if it works
or not
so it gives you a little more freedom to
just try
which i sees how wordy you have to be
too like
if i can tell this real short and quick
as a one-liner
and then oh there's three one-liners
about say
this isn't pertaining to mine but it's
three one-liners about a vacation
or a family in a car okay now it's a
vacation bit and like
now it's this is a three-minute chunk
that should go together because i think
there's a comedian that i've worked with
a few times
who's been in the business a long time
[Music]
whose success level has only risen so
high
he's known in our area for being a comic
who's not aware of the audience
and he's not aware of cobbling ideas
together in his own act
like he'll talk about something early in
his act and then go 10 minutes later
and then talk about something similar
without acknowledging that he knows it's
something an idea he's already talked
about
and so like i've seen comedians like
this besides this specific comedian
where it's like if you just pulled them
together
or you narratively if there was a reason
why you separated them
to make them bookends to a stronger idea
you would look like a mathematician of a
performer
because how many communities can you
think of when they do a callback
and they narratively have strung
together something that you as an
audience didn't even realize that it was
the same
theme or tone yeah that's important i
think
like people are wondering like when to
stop tweaking and stuff
i mean it's really in my opinion like
having some sort of deadline like you're
saying well
i have this recording coming up i better
start doing more headlining sets so i
can get ready
otherwise like i know i know jake is a
newer very new comic and it's like
keep tweaking keep writing keep growing
you know i mean
in my special you know i've been doing
it 10 years now
and like i was doing i did some jokes
that started out as a one-liner in year
three and then at year six
it grew into like a three-minute bit
that i then did
in my comedy special you know four years
later so it's like they evolve and
never get rid of yeah never get rid of
bits
like recycle them recycle even a line
from them like but i think part of that
comes from my like screenwriting and
playwriting
where maybe i'll start writing something
and it doesn't work out for whatever
reason
partially because i'm adhd no but i will
go back to
what 80d
works for me i'll look at you and then
i'll look it
um but i will i will it's called mining
so you can mine your material where even
if you're like well i don't do that joke
anymore because i've evolved as a
comedian
well what are you currently doing that
needs a punch-up of a big laugh or a big
joke or a quick joke like just a one
line
and you go back and you're like oh well
i'm talking
about dating and i've got this killer
one-line joke
that doesn't didn't fit with anything
else but i can throw in right here
because it works with what i'm talking
about when i used to date but maybe i'm
even a different person
like um i don't even think i made it on
my album i cut it
because i also questioned if i had heard
it before
and this i'll be candid i got called out
on my dry bar special
for doing a joke that people said was a
meme
um and it could very well have been
that i didn't remember being a meme and
that i thought
i mean not necessarily like the dane
cook like parallel thinking or whatever
i thought it was in retrospect now i'm
like oh yeah
maybe i thought that was like a cough
like a um
a water cooler kind of thing of like oh
yeah that's something people talk about
but like a joke i made was when talking
about online dating with my wife
that i had to ask her out on a date
because her eyes were beautiful
her eyes spoke to me her eyes said to me
that i would
i'd be making i would regret if i didn't
ask her on a date
and you know but i swear i'm not like a
serial killer
because the only thing that serial
killer and hopeless romantics have in
common is
they're always talking about the one
that got away
and i thought that was a joke that i
maybe had heard before
or some variation of and no matter like
how many times i've been
doing it i was like i don't feel
comfortable that this
isn't a completely original thought
so i'm gonna get rid of it i'm just
gonna stop doing it
because i have enough other things that
go with this bit
or whatever that i don't feel guilty or
weird about
saying it but that's also to say like
don't type
every joke you come up with into google
just make it so personal or
a spin of yours with your verbiage that
even
everything's been talked about you can't
talk about something that's not been
talked about
and there's no reason for you to be an
abstract version of who you are if
that's not who you are
somewhat as a person or as a defense
mechanism
so don't overthink yourself and when
we're thinking of writing
like like you're saying just keep
writing and new ideas we have a
question all the way from greece here
and i cannot
pronounce his name um my wife is great
yeah we have a lot of people from greece
in the life yeah we have a lot of comics
from greece that are in the group
and um he interesting we're all over the
world baby
we're in every continent but antarctica
so far
we're gonna everybody's got hot breath
get there
so he asks um when writing one-liners
how can someone find new premises all
the time
puns excluded
puns exclusive he's got a real achilles
teeth
for puns and people are like no no more
pun
um puns excluded
i wrote a thing about hot pockets the
other day
and someone on twitter again because i
use twitter as a notebook kind of
if i'm not making notes in my phone um
at the bathroom if you're writing public
transportation like even when i was in
chicago
and not doing stand-up all the time i
would
sit there
look around and i'd be like blind i'd
look at shoes
like someone wearing shirts like that's
an interesting pair of shoes like what's
a joke about shoes
like oh walk a mile in someone's shoes
like
unless they're clown shoes and then you
probably can't walk a mile because
that's going to hurt your feet
there's a one-liner like it's maybe not
funny but it's doing word association
and it's doing
uh i think one-liners are great for
observational humor
because you only have one line and for
me they either have to be relatable and
then an abstract turn
or it's relatable the whole way through
um
one liners are also good for titters
which titters is a funny word for just
chuckles
um to be a nice transition maybe between
bigger ideas you can do a couple of them
or one of them
i wouldn't worry about it being a new
thought like one thing that i think
one bit that came from my album that is
about horror movies
is what started as a one-liner was that
uh
the killers and horror movies never have
the body shape of someone like me
because you'd always know who the killer
was
and so like that turned into like a five
minute bit
of like me if i was wearing like the
ghost face outfit from scream
and you're like which one of these
teenagers is the killer
well it's the fat kid ricky like clearly
he has 80 pounds on all of us and while
he was chasing us through the woods he
stopped to lean on a tree
and breathe really heavy so like that
kind of started as
a a one-liner joke
there is a thing with being too harsh of
a self-editor which kind of goes with
what i was saying of like
don't google all of your material just
to make sure that like
there's a difference between carlos
mancia doing a bit from bill cosby
special that was on dvd and sold in the
five dollar bins at walmart
uh there's a difference between doing
what he has done or even dane cook
some of the the stuff that sounds almost
word for word
and then going and doing things that are
ubiquitous ideas that happen to
all of us which makes some of the ripest
comedy
because there are your interpretations
and spin on things yes
in your piece i think that's where a lot
of that comes from is
what is your point of view on things
what is your perspective
and that's where your sense of humor
that's where your voice is really going
to start to shine through is when you
start looking at
what is your personal opinion point of
view
experience that's when you're going to
start finding new premises all the time
because you're starting to look for
material through the filter of yourself
and not
oh what can i make funny or not it's
like well what is funny about me
or my quirks or my perspective
that you can then turn into funny
material
yeah and it's uh with this with the new
hour that i'm writing
is using a jumping off point is using my
old set list and topics
and going okay has anything happened
that is similar to this
that that i have new takes on or views
so like one of them is horror movies i
love horror movies
if i could show you my basement right
now i have an original name or an um
street poster i have a wall of sequel
posters so it's like
scream 2 psycho to
halloween 2 i love horror movies
so in my on my album spitting image
there's a bit about how how horror movie
killers don't look like me because you'd
know who they were
there'd be no mystery um that bit also
has
that in horror movies if they introduce
a dog that dog's gonna get killed and my
wife hates it
she can watch a million teenagers get
slaughtered
even kids but a dog or an animal
that's when she has a gripe um so i was
like okay
horror movies as part of my old set
listed outline
what other takes on horror movies do i
find
funny well we um i used to do a podcast
where all we would do is watch horror
movies
so i've i've seen enough good and bad
and
i've also had the gripe that thank god
cell phones didn't exist in old horror
movies
so like janet lee's character in psycho
would have never stayed at the bates
motel
if she could have pulled up yelp and
been like oh the guy who owns this has
some real serious mommy issues
i'll go to that bed and breakfast down
the road or like
you know or if they had cell phones at
neymar and elm street where they could
like
we could wake you up with an alarm at a
certain time or whatever like
uh texas chainsaw mask like
so i start looking at it with what i've
already done
as a nice access point to hopefully
open again open a door for something
that i'm already passionate about
because the confidence that you can put
on stage with what you're presenting
even if it's the first time you've ever
said it an audience
even if they aren't wanting you
most the time an audience you should
have in your head
wants you to succeed they want to have
fun they want to have a good time
every now and then there's the [ __ ]
who's the funniest person from their
office which they will self-proclaim
after the show um and his name's usually
like something like
jerry or dale um
and there's a very few amount of those
and most the time the audience will
rally against that person and shut them
down for
shut them down for you uh if they're a
heckler
but everyone has come there to give
their time to have a good time
so if you are confident with what you're
talking about and passionate
then they already accept what you're
saying
and even if they don't laugh first shows
on friday are a
great example of a two show night
in a seven o'clock show where they just
got off work
rush to get home have a shower and maybe
grab a bite
to eat before coming to the show they're
tired
they could love the show and you cannot
get a laugh or a little
titters and that doesn't mean that they
didn't love your show so
there's no reason to berate the audience
and be like well last night everyone
loved that joke why aren't you laughing
just go on with your show like you know
what you're doing you're there to
entertain
like your ego shouldn't be so hard if
they're not laughing
because early on in my career i would do
shows and the audience wouldn't laugh
and i'd be like wow they hated me
something i said really set them off
and the people that i was looking at who
are who i could see their faces
in the audience they would be like oh my
god you're so funny you're so good
and part of me wants to say a good way
to show that you're having a good time
is to laugh but you don't know what
their day was
exactly so oh yeah mike uh
mike's saying this is the most useful
info i've heard from one live show
great job both you guys new and
permanent fan
awesome by the album
it's linked in the comments if um glenn
if you want to repost it as well
so what yeah and leave a review if you
buy it on uh if you buy the physical
copy on circustrappies.com
slash ricky galore or circus trapeze you
can go there
if you get that you get a digital
download too so don't feel like you're
buying an archaic
piece of media you can still get it on
your phone or whatever device you listen
to
you just get a cool physical piece uh
which i still like
having you know like a vinyl or
something or cd
to get that artwork and the liner notes
um
but if you buy it on like even like
itunes or amazon
please leave a review and if you can
just because it helps me out screenshot
your review
and tag me on social media like on
twitter ricky glor
and just say hey this is my review i
hated this guy
like tag me i do not care like there's
no such thing as bad press either
oh and he said my name is spellable form
of
christos athens
oh man i really want to hop on facebook
and see if i can
yeah if i can get any green
and um i see jake ruble yeah jake rubel
okay you can see it oh christos
athena solas all right ethanol solas
all right thank you christos
um let's see we got uh a couple more
here this one comes from john cremarti
um you mentioned watching comedian
regularly
how much time do you spend watching
other comics do you watch other people's
specials
yeah i am in a weird spot sometimes when
i'm
writing and i want to be as distant from
other canadians as possible to feel the
gestations of new
ideas and feel like that i'm not
influenced by anything
again i watch the comics that i dig
usually i don't think
come from my voice um
i grew up watching a lot of old
television as i mentioned monkeys
i i loved
watching hope and crosby movies the road
pictures
bing crosby and bob hope not as much the
martin and lewis but i like dean martin
they were meaner
like marx three stooges because they
weren't as mean in the slapstick
um like growing up people would always
be like oh man
like i used to do a chris farley
impression especially when i was
clean-shaven
and i stopped doing it because i hate it
after shows people be like oh man you're
the reincarnation of chris farrell
um i don't know why that bugged me like
people had a good time and they remember
me great whatever
but like my always the comeback that i
wanted to say when i was a younger
younger comic was
well i like david spade more i like whit
more and i love farley
i love them together they are the best
they ever were together
um my favorite comic from snl
was phil yeah that cast like phil
hartman
dana carvey kevin neal and john lovitz
nora dunn
jan hooks victoria jackson mike myers
so like old school kind of comedy and
what phil hartman
did which then like gave me a great
appreciation for everyone
who was considered the glue on snl
that's your dan
aykroyd your phil heart and your bill
hater
will ferrell to a degree but he actually
expands a little farther than that
um but so like i'll watch
stuff that maybe knit isn't necessarily
stand up
but it's kind of the humor that i'm
feeling so if like i'm writing something
that is joke intensive i might watch a
stand-up like a john mullaney
or um trevor noah
and um i'm trying to think of
what special oh i really enjoyed
seth meyer's especial lobby baby
um i it was i've gotten such more of
appreciation for him
since he started doing late night with
seth meyers than i
ever did when he was on snl except for
the last couple years that he did
weekend update
he is a um he is a comic i really like
his mind and his approach
if anyone's not listening to it not that
he needs plugs but his podcast which is
an abbreviated version
of his late night show even the one from
home
he usually does one segment which is a
closer look
which is just on one topic and then he
does a guest
it's a 20 minute listen it's phenomenal
especially to give you like an
unabreasted version of the um
political climate which i mean sure
it's biased because he is a democrat but
he's also a humanitarian
which is that's how i feel that like
yeah
his ladies may be democrat but he's also
pointing out the atrocities
that are happening from every angle so
um
yeah that's what i'll listen to and or
watch
when i want to get inspiration how did
this get made with jason manzoukis
i couldn't be any different more
different than jason manzukis there's
another greek
if you're greek yeah um it's
fantastic uh
but yeah there are there are also times
where i feel like i have to remove
myself
from anything comedian comedic to
feel like that i'm getting a um an
earnest
interpretation of where i want to go
with my writing
cool all right let's um
let's take a few more minutes here i
gotta get out of here at 8 30. my
in-laws are here
um so i need to go
spend a little family time joe what are
you doing talking to yourself in that
room come out here play punches
yeah they hear me yell because i do the
right tank club every morning they've
been hearing me yelling every morning at
10 a.m in here they're like is that his
job honey
this is who you married does he make
money oh
that's the best question to be asked
when you're doing comedy starting off
so how much does that pay nothing right
yep how far are you driving
oh yeah let's uh so let's try to give
them like
quick quick sound bites on these last
few years i want to i want to get to
peeps because i appreciate all y'all
hanging out and all the comments
and all the sharing but all of y'all
saying how helpful this is and
everything we really do appreciate that
interaction
um and also if you want to ask me if if
we don't get to something or you
want something to be expounded on even
more feel
free to send me a message via twitter
because i think my mailbox is open
or uh write me a tweet and i will answer
it
oh you know what the crazy timing of
that is justin williams
says thanks for replying to my tweet
today and he has a question
that's so cool that's so cool so he said
yeah thanks for replying to my tweet
today
have you ever done a show and actually
real quick i feel like someone else
um asked a similar question
i want to make sure um
oh yeah okay and earl anderson kind of
on the same line here
so um justin asked if you ever done a
show where a set killed one night
but bombs the next um and then
it kind of ties into earls where it's
like
he asks
let's see have you ever had material
that killed for a while
and then it's like meh how do you handle
it so i guess the overall topic is like
yeah what do you
what do you do with material that maybe
kills one night and then the next it
doesn't what's your
do you have an approach that you found
helpful i don't think you should parade
an audience but there are sometimes
where the audience sucks
and that's okay um it's okay to then go
that was a one-off
for whatever the permutations are with
sound with light
with what time the show was with how
the people who organized or the venue
put the show together
could be out of your control also you
could have been off that night
you could have been thinking about a lot
of things that you didn't really
recognize in your presentation of the
show or the persona
that you're putting off um
that doesn't mean that you're a failure
or
what you did was gonna be
bad like that every night leading on
um if you did something one night and it
didn't do well the next night
kind of the same answer there's a lot of
variables
that i think you have to be cognizant of
of going
i could easily beat myself up and say
it's me
i could easily on the other end of that
prism go
the audience was just awful um i think
it's a little bit of give and take like
look at look at both of those listen to
your audio that you recorded or if
you're at the stage where
i said audio starting off video
is once you need to start
doing precision work on your delivery
of your physicality of what things could
aid
the things that you are saying by the
body language that you're giving off or
by movement
by pauses by the way you're showing them
by a facial expression
those i think are the seasonings
to whatever your set is first get the
audio then you can do video
i don't think you need to video record
everything it's just a waste of time
you're not gonna
watch it listen to it while you're going
to your next show or you're driving the
next day or something
um but yeah if something doesn't work
that did work even if it's the first
time you did it
i don't think you should get rid of
anything until you've done it 10 times
and that means also trying it off trying
it in different positions
if you are if you're like
say if it's your child which jokes are
considered babies a lot of times
you want to give it the best chance that
it can at succeeding
so don't put it at the beginning of your
show
you're really excited because you just
wrote it and you're like this is killer
put it in the middle every time no
matter like
how good you think it is do the try and
true
opening even if you think this thing's
gonna be the new best opening ever
don't do it first don't do it last put
it smack dab even if it's five minutes
do an opening couple killer one-liners
do this new thing
do your closer if it's longer set
always just put it in the middle and if
it doesn't work one night
keep doing it uh part of the the
question you asked was
you've been doing it for a while and it
doesn't work re-evaluate
how much you're sucking at doing it so
listen to that audio or watching the
camera and going
oh you're not passionate or confident
about it
you look like you're just getting
through this bit is that
why it's not working so that means you
should do it better or you should just
get rid of it
if you're going to deep six your own set
every night
because you're not going to give this
bit
the energy in that it needs if you're
over it
yeah get over like move it along
all right so we hope that was sound
bitey enough yeah that's
yeah there's yeah there's a there's some
good questions coming in and honestly
like
um i see you uh my here
and robin and michelle and
um yeah i see your questions here
uh but they're going to be in the
comments so even if like you
on facebook without them tweeting you i
guess you could just respond here
um we could figure out a way because
i'll release this as a podcast
on youtube as well but um
yeah or it's facebook follow me on my
comedian's facebook page and if you want
to repost them or whatever i'll answer
them there too if that's easier for
people
okay cool yeah yeah so reach out
to uh ricky after you get his album
because um you know support a fellow
comedian
yeah and and glenn the man behind circus
trapeze is good people
i mean when i was researching i didn't
know if i wanted to do a special or a
comedy album and i was researching both
and glenn's article about independently
producing a comedy album is
your one-stop shop for knowing
everything about
releasing a comedy album it's it's the
most thorough
resource i was able to find in hours of
googling and research
so glenn is definitely an asset to the
comedy community we're gonna have on
here so
it's all four comics by comics here and
that's why we had ricky on the show
today
um before we wrap up is there anything
else you want
uh the hot breath of earth to know here
ricky
did ricky freeze wait
yeah wait were we just wrapping up and
then you froze
oh my gosh what kind of timing is that
oh my shows starting in march got
cancelled
uh oh am i frozen
can you hear me am i still here oh you
are now oh what
timing even even the internet's like
come on guys
land this plane here been doing this for
too long but reach
yeah reach out to ricky with your
questions please i mean this this guy is
a comedy resource
and he is now like officially in the hot
breath the verse so this is not the last
time we're gonna connect
but reach out yeah reach out to him with
more questions but please go ahead and
uh
finish what you were saying no i was
just going to say since uh all my shows
started getting cancelled
in uh march i'm pretty much i only
have a couple dates that are still
tentative here and there between now and
the end of 2020
which would have been a good opportunity
to sell them albums so please buy it
um gifted to someone who 100 clean
comedy
and like
[Music]
physical copy and you send it to someone
you put in an address of a friend or a
family member
so that's a good reason to buy it um the
thing that i've been doing to stay
creative
i did one zoom show which was great
glenn put it on and i did it and i had a
good time doing it i worked some new
material
but there isn't an audience there and i
i love entertaining like i love
making an audience happy so i started
doing a weekly
youtube series called weekend update
with uh norm mcdonfell so it's a puppet
that does
it kind of an homage to weekend update
it's evolved into a sesame street
meets daily show but it's every week on
the youtube channel weekend update
and check it out it's hosted by this guy
hey
hi i'm narmac donsat and i'm just trying
to give you
a straight dope baby so yeah just come
over to our weekend update on yeah
youtube and i just give you all the news
that's happening we got music
videos we got editorial pieces
we got musical guests oh and look at our
back catalog and we got a lot of ex-snl
cast members who've come on and done
some stuff so uh
how you doing charles did you get asked
to come on the new
uh yeah the new arrested development
series
yeah sounds good nice no
i think i'm raising you nice nose
your nose is taking up the whole
it keeps cutting out you broke the
internet you're so
ugly you broke the internet
oh that's so mean oh you wrote me
usually i get seth rogen
i didn't stay michael sarah was ugly
oh well i was saying norm is ugly
answered on
twitter i didn't oh no it was the sock
puppet that said it i didn't say that
it's triumph the insult sock
that's doing sock puppets
yes all i have left is subscribe to
weekend update we've got a lot of great
comedians
throughout the united states who are in
the same predicament as me who are
submitting pieces who are writing jokes
uh luke noel who's a cast member snl
submitted a couple songs gary kroger if
you're an snl aficionado he was on from
82 to 85 with julie louise dreyfus
he submitted a whole impression
character piece and it was amazing
so yeah please subscribe to that it's a
weekly show seven o'clock on saturdays
it drops
also follow me follow me
ricky glor on twitter and follow me on
facebook
awesome and we will link that's all i
got we will link
to the album in the show notes in the
video description it's also in the
comments here
if you have any other questions that
popped up either during this or after
reach out to ricky you know he's he you
could tell his heart's in the right
place and
enjoying not only comedy but also
helping other comedians which is what
we're all about here at hot breath so
ricky i'm so glad this happened and uh
thanks for
sharing your viable time and information
with us
thank you for having me let me bring out
my puppet of course
my puppet as well i just had a character
debut that everyone's roasting
so that's that's good to know all right
so go forth hot breath the verse reach
out to her
with any uh questions and join our
facebook group if you're listening or
watching this go join that facebook
group
you're gonna learn a lot of comedy it's
all
a comedy resource that i wish existed
when i started comedy 10 years ago
so doing positive things here and ricky
you're now
a part of it so welcome to the hot
breath verse my friend
yeah all right well everyone have a good
night
we will see you tomorrow at 10 a.m for
the right tank club everyone goodbye
[Music]
hey hot brother and sister if you love
comedy as much as we do here at hot
breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch
more videos to get even more comedy tips